yesterday we did an entire story about
the 75 year old protester Martin Gugino
who was attacked by Buffalo Police
shoved onto the ground hit the back of
his head caused bleeding from his ear
now I'm not going to give you that full
story again because we just did it
yesterday but the big shock since
yesterday is that Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaylee McInerney has doubled
and tripled down on Donald Trump's
attacks of the protester not of the
police what we go back a little bit
yesterday Donald Trump tweeted about
this altercation quote Buffalo
protesters shoved by police could be an
Tifa provocateur 75 year old Martin
Gugino was pushed away after appearing
to scan police communications in order
to black out the equipment Oh a n I
watched he fell harder than was pushed
was aiming scanner could be a setup so
this was a where did Trump get this as
he says this is a story from Oh a n
which is a wacky it's even crazier than
Fox News they did a segment promoting
these baseless conspiracies Trump bought
it hook line and sinker it was sick so
yesterday Trump's press secretary Haley
Mac and Annie is asked about this on Fox
& Friends and she doubles down with a
complete trash response let's take a
look at it yesterday the president
Kaylee was a tweeted out that this
Buffalo protester the 75 year old who
was shoved to the ground by a police
officer might have been part of Antipa
and a provocateur in order to get that
type of reaction just to paraphrase
could you expand on that does the
president think that this this guy is
part of an Tifa so the president was
raising questions based on a report that
he saw are there questions that need to
be asked in every case we can't jump on
one side okay so I want to interrupt us
for a moment
Trump was asking questions based on the
report he saw the report he saw was a
completely speculative irresponsible
segment from a channel called Oh a n
which Trump increasingly loves because
they kowtow to him a hundred percent of
the time rather than 98 percent of the
time which is what Fox News does it's a
segment which is sir
no facts whatsoever it was mere
speculation that she says is the basis
for Trump's tweet let's continue every
case we can't jump on one side without
looking at all the facts at play this
individual had some very questionable
tweets and profanity-laden tweets okay I
have to stop again Kaylee McKenna nee
says 75 year old Martin Gugino
who was attacked by police tweeted
questionable things that had swears
let's just apply basic critical thinking
did the officers interacting with googy
know know about his tweets when they
knocked him down causing him to bleed
out of his ear and putting him in the
hospital for nearly a week of course
they didn't they didn't know who he was
and most importantly most importantly
tweeting swear words doesn't mean that
it's warranted for police to knock you
over and put you in the hospital right I
thought this was America this is
disgusting the president's press
secretary asserting as a defense of
Trump attacking the protester that the
protester once tweeted questionable
things with swear words if you can
imagine anything more milquetoast this
is a tragedy let's continue some
profanity-laden tweets about police
officers of course no one condones any
sort of violence we need the appropriate
amount of force used in any interaction
but there are a lot of questions in that
case in fact you had 56 police officers
who resigned in protest of how their
fellow officers were treated so there's
the grand finale we're all disgusted
that so many officers resigned in
defense of the cops who did this but
Caylee is citing the resignations as
proof that the officers were in the
right the reality is that Buffalo PD has
a very long history of this type of get
in line no matter what they've done sort
of nonsense and that's exactly what
we're seeing here it's horrifying that
Trump even stepped into this by tweeting
things that were antagonistic of the
protester and now his press secretary is
doubling down then she was asked about
it again during her press briefing so
the clip I showed you is from Fox in the
morning yesterday then she did a press
briefing starting about 4550 minutes
late and she
pulled down let's take a look at that so
much regret tweeting out a baseless
conspiracy theory about a 75 year old
protester on the morning George Floyd's
funeral the president was asking
questions about an interaction and a
video clip he saw and the president has
the right to ask those questions regret
tweeting out this protester was
assaulted the president does not regret
standing up for law enforcement men and
women across this country
so here Kaley tries to make it about
Trump standing up for law enforcement
this actually weakens law enforcement
this is really an important it this is
not a trivial matter here when law
enforcement does something so obviously
wrong
and the president defends it it reduces
trust in law enforcement which worsens
the situation on the ground
if Trump actually criticized the
officers here it would increase trust
that when law enforcement so obviously
misbehaves there will be agreement that
they misbehaved we all lose when Donald
Trump does this and just one more piece
of this clip about so-called facts again
coming up rather president to have fast
before he tweets anything out he's the
President of the United States the
President did have facts before he
tweeted out that undergirded his
question is conspiracy theories most
conspiracy no not at all I won't
acknowledge that because look you had
let's contrast this to the George Floyd
situation which that horrific video that
we all saw every single police officer
that I saw across the country came out
and said this is an inexcusable action
and I condemn this police officer in
this case there were 57 police officers
who said I resign in protest so again
with the police officers who resigned
who actually should be ashamed of
themselves but more importantly Kaylee
McKenna nee says Trump did have facts
when he tweeted and repeated those
attacks against 75 year old Martin googy
no he did not
all Trump had when he tweeted about this
attacking Martin Gugino were the
baseless conspiratorial assertions of an
OE n segment this is sick and remember
that there is a I don't want to call it
a strategy but there
is a political impact to this which is
that sewing division is good for Trump
if he can get people doubting who's good
and bad even in such an obvious
interaction as the one that Martin
Gugino had with police if people can be
arguing about well you know whose side
are we on
that prevents people from uniting about
anything and that is exactly what Trump
needs Trump needs a divided country so
that they don't unite and realize it's
obviously time for a change it's
obviously time for a change in November
let's not fall for it
quick reminder chess tournament David
Pakman show chess tournament Tuesday
June 16 at 8:00 p.m. Eastern I hope you
will join I hope you will play we did
this once before had 500 participants
let's go for a thousand but we will be
doing the tournament on the website Li
Ches org Li Ches org this is all free
you're invited it's free to everybody
I'll be streaming the tournament and
anybody who wants to play can play all
skill levels welcome Tuesday 8 p.m. June
16th remember to get the David Pakman
show daily podcast on whatever
podcasting app you prefer iTunes
stitcher google play Spotify all of
those are available and lastly let me
know what you make of this entire Martin
Gugino thing I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and I look forward to hearing from you
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic
to check it out on blinka blink east
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video